rien ne se passe, il me veut de cet
Arkansas, nous avons eu trois enfants portés
disparus depuis la nuit dernière, trois jeunes
garçons assassinés de sang-froid, il est apparu
qu'ils avaient eu des relations sexuelles perverses,
pensez-vous que ces crimes étaient
motivés par des croyances occultes oui, arrêtés
à deux heures  quarante-quatre heures accusé de trois
chefs de meurtre passible de la peine capitale emprisonnement à vie
sans libération conditionnelle mort par
injection létale
un cas avec des aveux serait
plus facile qu'un cas sans
preuve directe la déclaration a été mise dans sa
bouche par la police ils ont
bien pensé puis ils ont lié  Lui, ils sont bien liés,
voici l'État de l'Arkansas qui refuse de
laisser la vérité briller sur cette affaire.
Damien vous a-t-il invité à une réunion,
moi satanique qui n'était qu'un grand menteur, en
réalité, vous avez affaire à un
crime horrible, il veut son trésor
là-bas.  des carrières étaient en jeu les options de
réouverture l'affaire lui a été présentée
d'accord avec non nous les avons reconnus coupables nous avons
fini ils ne croient pas que les habitants de l'
Arkansas seront satisfaits jusqu'à ce qu'il y
ait un nouveau procès
non seulement l'État obtient  laisse tomber
mais la personne qui tue les arcs de ses enfants
est toujours là, marchant dans la
rue